[Música]
bueno quiero comenzar
planteando dos cuestionamientos el
primero es cuál es la clase más
interesante que han tomado
cake
y segundo cuál es la clase que les ha
parecido más aburrida tal vez que no les
haya llamado la atención esto que puede
ser como parte de un programa académico
de su carrera no actualmente por ahí
alguna clase que tengan ustedes en la
mente incluso como parte de sus hobbies
bueno estas dos preguntas he tenido la
oportunidad de plantear las en distintos
escenarios en américa latina donde he
tenido la oportunidad de estar y
derivado de esto pues los chicos me han
dado su retroalimentación en torno a me
parecen aburridas todas aquellas
materias que tienen que ver con ciencia
y que tienen que ver con el desarrollo
de investigación que tienen que ver con
este
favorecimiento de competencias a los
chicos respecto a habilidades
científicas y bueno es aquí donde como
bueno investigadora yo me di a la tarea
de acercarme a sus docentes no a
escuchar la contraparte y saber que
estaba pasando y en este sentido muchos
de ellos me comentaban bueno los chicos
no tienen esta facilidad por las
materias les parece aburrido no les
gusta no le ven la utilidad la vez que
en muchos casos ellos optan por salirse
porque no tienen conciencia de lo que
significa en un futuro aplicar este tipo
de materias a su futuro profesional y
bueno efectivamente ahí es donde yo me
percaté que incluso yo misma como
docente debo de aplicar la pasión la
conciencia y la practicidad en este tipo
de materias
y fue aquí donde me di a la tarea de
hacer una reflexión de que toda acción
tiene una reacción y efectivamente esto
era consecuencia de nosotros como
docentes en este sentido muchas veces el
docente es impuesto a las materias y de
talman de tal manera que nosotros
estamos generando en los chicos esa
separación de lo que son materias que
tienen que ver con ciencia muchas
situaciones derivadas de cuestiones
administrativas porque el maestro no
tenía el perfil pero me falta entonces
necesito meterlo al aula y bueno pues lo
siento te toca este semestre te toca
este ciclo escolar dar la clase así que
bueno esto trae una consecuencia en el
chico de alejamiento de aislamiento de
sept y sismo de desinterés o de
aburrimiento sin embargo esto es una
idea totalmente
disparatada la vez que la investigación
nos va a servir de muchas formas
nosotros mismos somos investigadores
natos somos exploradores desde el
momento en el que nacemos y esto lo
podemos ver en nuestros hijos en edades
tempranas donde estamos viendo como la
pasión de explorar de entender lo que
está pasando es totalmente favorecedor
para ellos entonces está smith este es
mi tercer eje respecto a esta reflexión
a la que he llegado y en este sentido la
verdad es que hemos tenido experiencias
todos respecto a la ciencia o la
investigación que nos ha alejado
tal vez una mala experiencia tal vez
nosotros mismos como docentes los hemos
alejado o en muchas situaciones un libro
un equipo de trabajo o porque nos ha
sido muy cómodo decir quiero seguir a la
multitud y si mis compañeros dicen que
es aburrido entonces es aburrido y
entonces qué ocurre tiene una
consecuencia y nos alejamos
tenía
pues algo mi cuarta reflexión ha sido en
torno a la utilidad a lo sencillo y lo
cercano que es la ciencia a nosotros
entonces es fundamental para nuestra
vida cotidiana y los vamos y lo vamos a
ver en las creaciones en los desarrollos
tecnológicos que tenemos en las
invenciones tan sólo en este momento
todos tenemos un dispositivo móvil y
nuestro transporte transporte
el proyector de cine las aplicaciones la
moda el maquillaje de alguna o de otra
manera todos estamos en constante
apoyo constante constante actividad con
esta con este quehacer que la ciencia
entonces es una idea disparatada decir
que no tenemos ninguna cercanía con ella
en quinto es importante y resulta
fundamental para todas las naciones en
este sentido vamos a ver que más del 1%
del producto interno bruto se está
invirtiendo en ciencia y tecnología
sobre todo en países como dinamarca
singapur corea del sur japón australia y
alemania eeuu todos estos países
invierten más del 2.5 por ciento en
materia de desarrollo e innovación
científica entonces estos países
imagínense que nos están promoviendo
promoviendo américa latina' de este tipo
de tecnologías porque nosotros somos
dependientes de sus procesos si ustedes
se ponen a pensar un poquito de qué
marca es el teléfono que portan en este
momento alguien tiene aquí algún
automóvil o algún teléfono que sea
mexicano
que sea colombiano bolivariano me
explico entonces en este sentido qué es
lo que está haciendo américa latina
tenemos el ejemplo de brasil que está
invirtiendo más del 1 por ciento de su
producto interno bruto en estados unidos
corea del sur-japón tan solo estos
países incluido la unión europea aporta
el 78 por ciento de los 1.6 millones de
dólares que se están sumando a esta
causa a nivel mundial solamente estas
naciones
ahora bien qué está haciendo américa en
este sentido ese es el reto que nos
tenemos que llevar y no solamente como
empresarios sino también desde desde los
distintos roles en los que estamos
jugando qué pasa con las universidades
bueno pues tenemos ahí universidades que
ponen el ejemplo a nivel mundial como lo
es
oxford stanford cambridge la universidad
del colegio en londres donde bueno de
acuerdo con el industrial research
institute estas universidades están en
la vanguardia en materia de desarrollo
tecnológico sin duda alguna ustedes han
escuchado hablar de marcas como samsung
como intel como microsoft como novartis
como google
entre otras como toyota
johnson and johnson panasonic sonic
estas marcas están liderando hoy por hoy
este tipo de
el desarrollo tecnológico y bueno como
empresarios como emprendedores que
estamos haciendo en este sentido para
copiar estas mejores prácticas y
mantenernos a iu de manera innovadora
con una solidez económica en este
sentido
ahora el sexto gen derivado de un
estudio en el que tuve la oportunidad de
participar con el consejo nacional de
ciencia y tecnología y el instituto de
evaluación de educación nos percatamos
que uno de los principales retos
[Música]
y sus manos
en el sentido que nos sensibilizamos
actuales
voy a ver a los niños con actividades
comparaciones muy complejas que no somos
más tiempo después de ser cinco minutos
en cinco minutos que manera muy
consciente muy práctica
nosotros estamos compartiendo a nuestros
hijos la pasión de estar
las instituciones de la marina es la
diversidad suspensión de las actividades
administrativo las actividades que
tienen los docentes en el sentido de la
investigación
entonces son estos retos circunstancias
naturales
sobre todo en nuestro país
sin embargo en este sentido el reloj
sigue sobre la mesa
enseñar con conciencia enseña a utilizar
habilidades como el desarrollo del
pensamiento crítico la resolución de
problemas el análisis de datos que nos
permitan tomar decisiones en
circunstancias habituales de nuestra
vida y esto sin duda alguna nos puede
dar la ciencia el desarrollo de la
investigación
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e